thank you
the one-on push-up is a favorite among
Legends Rocky Balboa Goku Bruce Lee need
I say more but it's also much more than
that because the one arm push-up also
happens to be one of the most powerful
bodyweight exercises with the most
functional carryover there is that's
once you can do it properly and that's
where things get a little bit tricky
because they want to push up unlocking
it is just the first step on this
journey there's a lot more nuance and a
lot more to master when it comes to this
movement so in this video I'm going to
talk about not only how to perform your
first one armed push-up I'm going to
talk about why you should do it and why
it's so beneficial and we're going to
discuss the small changes to your
Technique they'll help to get the very
most out of it because that's enough
blabbing time to actually do a one-arm
push-up so this is what it's going to
look like essentially
foreign
[Music]
move there are a few things to note if
you're going to do this correctly the
first thing is you need full range of
motion that means the chest is coming
all the way down to the ground and back
up you're not resting on the ground but
you want your nipple to touch the floor
if you're topless which you should be if
you're doing it correctly you've heard
of Aster grass this is nipples to Grass
anything less than that is not full
range of motion it's not a full rep and
whilst I'm not a stickler for that
obviously if you want to do shorter reps
that's fine too if you want to do it
technically correctly then you do need
to go all the way down to the ground
you're also I'm kicking my elbow quite
close to my body you don't want the
elbow to flare out like this rather keep
it nicely tucked by your side even more
so than you would do for a regular
push-up you want to depress the scapula
so shoulders down the opposite of
shrugging this is probably the hardest
thing to do throughout the movement it's
also good if you can control the
scapular protraction and retraction so
that at the top of the movement you're
protracting the scapula and
straightening the arm as much as
possible again these are just if you
want to make sure you're doing the
absolutely correct technique if you
really want to do it properly don't hold
on to your leg or your back again this
is kind of cheating because it does make
the movement slightly easier it makes
the anti-rotation portion of movement
slightly easier if you want to focus
more on chest strength on shoulder
strength triceps then you can use that
to support your torso and thereby make
this slightly more of an isolated
movement but if you want to do it really
properly and if you want to challenge
that rotational strength that
anti-rotational strength keeping your
torso straight forwards then you want to
keep the arm free I tend to keep it on
my body just because it makes a marginal
difference and it's actually just more
comfortable to hold onto your leg or put
it behind your back or something
if you want to get yourself into the
most mechanically advantageous position
possible then as you bring yourself down
towards the ground slightly internally
rotate the hand turn it inwards and this
will give you a kind of Corkscrew effect
and help you to generate just that
little bit more power from there
similarly consider to what extent you
want to spray the legs apart by widening
your stance so you again spread your
weight more and have less of a
rotational Force to battle against
allowing you to train harder on the pecs
and perhaps pump out extra repetitions
but if you want to do it really properly
and if you want to challenge yourself
more then bring your legs nice and close
together again when you see Bruce Lee do
this his legs are almost touching each
other which makes it even more
incredible of course he's also doing it
on just a finger on a thumb which is
awesome
one armed push-ups are undoubtedly one
of the most badass looking exercises
going but if you really want to look
like a badass then you also need to
think about your skincare that's why I'm
excited to introduce today's sponsor
tiege Hanley tiege Hanley have helped me
to start and maintain my own skincare
routine and they provide everything that
a guy could possibly need to look and
feel great basically you get a selection
of different products along with some
really easy and simple to follow
instructions that show you when and how
to imply each product but they have over
5 000 5 Star reviews from customers all
around the world so clearly they're
doing something right I recommend
starting with their level 1 system which
comes with all the basics a daily face
wash to get rid of the dirt and Grime on
your skin are two times per week
exfoliating scrub to get rid of dead
skin cells an AM moisturizer with SPF 20
because you should always be protecting
your skin from the sun and a PM
moisturizer to help your skin stay
hydrated and healthy throughout the
night as well as getting amazing skin
members of teach Hanley also get lots of
other benefits including at least 20 of
the rich price the ability to customize
their box exclusive monthly deals and
the option to pause or cancel at any
time and free us shipping and low cost
shipping to most other countries and
because tiege Hanley is sponsoring
today's video they're offering my
viewers a great deal just click the
first link in the description and you'll
get 30 off your first box plus a free
gift don't miss out on this amazing deal
click that link and get started today
so why one-arm push-ups what's so good
about them well to start with it is a
really cool move and that's not a small
thing because cool moves are cool and
working towards a really awesome move is
really motivating for a lot of people
and the great thing about the one-on
push-up is that whilst it looks
superhuman it's actually attainable
unlike things like the planche or a
handstand push-up which are going to
take you months if not years of training
to develop the core strength the
straight arm strength the body control
it will not push-up while difficult is a
much more achievable goal and a great
thing to work towards and it's this
difficulty level that actually makes it
perfect because once you learn the
one-on push-up you're essentially making
regular push-ups far far more difficult
if you can perform 31 on push-ups then
you're crazy strong so if you're
currently doing hundreds of push-up
repetitions and not getting a lot out of
them then learning the one-on push-up is
a great way to make things more
difficult for yourself and turn your
body into a walking gym now you can
adequately train the chest the shoulders
the triceps the core no matter where you
are with no equipment if you can perform
10 that's really really good so now
you're in the rep range that you need
for building muscle creating strength
but that core strength is where things
get really interesting because the
one-on push-up isn't just a exercise
that targets the chest the shoulders and
the triceps it's a movement that targets
the core and in particular it's an
anti-rotational movement meaning you're
trying to prevent your body from
twisting down to the ground by bracing
the core this is really important
because you're training yourself in the
transverse plane the rotational plane
that I always talk about that's so
important and that's so overlooked for
athletes the rotational plane is
absolutely essential throwing a punch
walking running throwing a ball all of
these are things that require rotation
of the core if you're not training this
at all then you're missing out and
actually this might have been one of the
big secrets to Bruce Lee's incredible
athleticism if you watch him move his
entire torso moves at once that means
that when he's punching he's not wasting
he's not losing energy there are no
energy leaks and we know that he was a
guy who performed lots of one-armed
push-ups and it also strengthens that
connection between the show older and
the opposite hip which again is
essential for so many movements like
running etc for restless for martial
artists for athletes this is essential
training and for everybody else because
you rotate whenever you push anything or
pull anything it's not normal to keep
the body rigid that doesn't make any
sense that we only have a train in the
sagittal plane
so if you like the idea of learning one
arm push-up but you don't know how to go
about it where do you start what
exercises can help you well of course
you want to master your push-ups do as
many push-ups as you can it's also a
great idea to strengthen yourself in the
rotational plane so doing things like
wood cutters or even one-armed cable
press can be a great way to build that
strength you can also do this with a
band at the same time you can use
movements like the Archer push-up here
you're going to be in the regular
push-up position you're going to go down
more on one side using the other arm
only to support you a little bit so this
will build up that strength
you can also try incline one-armed
push-ups you're doing one arm push-up
against a raised surface such as doing
it on a weight bench makes a little bit
easier and that's probably one of the
most useful ones because there you're
you're training the whole movement
pattern you're not only training
yourself to be strong on that one side
but also fighting that rotational Force
just to a slightly lesser degree and if
you do that and combine it with those
other three movements and you'll master
that one-arm push-up in no time at all
you can also use the elevated incline
one-armed push-up to get all those same
benefits that you would do normally when
doing a one-arm push-up if you can't do
the full thing or you can also use it as
a mechanical drop set so do as many
one-armed push-ups as you can then move
on to an incline and continue to do
those one-around push-ups
of course if you want to make the
movement more difficult then there are
also tons of options a great option is a
decline one arm push-up of course this
basically makes the angle steeper puts
more pressure on the pecs and the
triceps doesn't really make the
rotational aspects any harder in fact it
might make it slightly easier but in
terms of pure shoulder training this is
a great way to increase the difficulty I
should have definitely elevated a little
bit there got some stuff to work on
still
another good option is the Clapping one
on push-up which is more of a Showboat
move but it's also a great one for
building explosive power and now you
also have to brace that core as you land
which has an additional challenge to it
as well or of course you can just add a
weight vest which is another way to make
it more difficult too or remove fingers
like Bruce Lee and one more option
that's fantastic and this is a way that
you can make any exercise more
challenging and highly valuable is the
Quasi isometric one-arm push-up what
you're going to do here is you're just
going to perform the repetition really
really slowly you're aiming to get to
the point where it takes you a whole
minute or even two minutes to perform
one repetition this requires so much
isometric strength so much bracing so
much control and precision and it's just
a brilliant way to build up for the
movement this is also a great way to get
stronger by practicing the one arm
push-up in an inclined manner but by
going very slowly you'll build that
isometric strength that you need
so thanks a ton for watching you guys I
hope you found this one useful and
interesting if you want a training
program that takes movements like this
that focus on more than just Aesthetics
and your numbers on a few big lifts but
actually improve functional performance
then you might enjoy my ebook and
training program super functional
training 2.0 the protein performance
system that comes with over two hours of
video tutorials a fully booked over 80
pages long and actually includes the
one-on push-up as well as many other
similar movements and progressions that
make it easier and harder for any level
I'll leave a link to that in description
down below either way thank you so much
for watching this one guys and I'll see
you next time fun fact I literally don't
know where I am I don't know the way
back to my car as Christoph sang I am
lost in the woods so uh wish me luck and
bye for now
[Music]
[Music]